most of these kids never walk in their
lives
the first thing that that arises is
the smile the kids start to smile
and then they look at their feet
i am elena garcia i am a roboticist a
robotics engineer and a scientist at the
spanish national research council
i am also the founder of marcy bionics
the company that is transferring the
technology of exoskeletons to the
society
six-year-old alejandro has cerebral
palsy he took his first steps with the
help of this device the world's first
adaptable robotic exoskeleton for
children
17 million children in the world in the
world need this kind of technology
so because we knew we had the knowledge
the know-how
and we started to develop this
technology and in three years we had the
first prototype of a pediatric
exoskeleton that was tested
once we we showed these results to the
community we started to receive the
demand from
clinicians families all over the world
because all of them
needed this kind of technology
the battery-powered device provides
mobility and strength to help patients
walk and it adapts to each patient's
needs and symptoms
there are two different ways of working
with the device one is a passive mode
where if the kid doesn't know how to
move because it never worked the device
is able to provide the gate pattern
specific for that child but is
programmed for for him so it simply
repeats the motions and it's working
forward and bad work backwards there's
another way where the exoskeleton is
waiting for the kid to make a force so
there's a threshold of force that the
physiotherapist can program
and until the patient is not surpassing
this
threshold in force the device is not
moving step by step the child is the one
that is
governing the motion of the device
[Music]
they feel they are able to do
things that they were not able to do
before
they feel that they are able to do
things like their peers they improve
their self-esteem
at the end this is like a global
integral therapy not only physical
therapy but is somehow related to the
personal development of the kid
[Music]
a
parents were also scientists and she
says science has been in her life since
she was born
it was difficult for me not to be a
scientist at the very beginning i wanted
to be an artist but
my parents brought me to the
way of the of science
and i really enjoyed science i i wanted
to be a roboticist because this was the
way i could merge the engineering and
the creativity of arts robotics is like
a mix of engineering and arts
elena garcia armada
helena come here
elena was recently awarded the popular
prize at the european adventure award
2022
and she has big ambitions for the future
my idea is to reduce size weight so it
can even be introduced inside the body
of the people but this is a very
long-term vision of course we need to
to work a lot on this
it's really wonderful how you can feel
when you see at the end that all your
work is reflecting into the improvement
in health of so many children
[Music]
you